Dad!
Oh, my darling! Happy Birthday.
Dad, guess what? You know my friend Amanda?
Yeah.
Her cousins asked us to spend vacation with them in Paris. I really, really wanna go.
Hi Daddy!
You were supposed to call me when you left.
There's someone here.
Oh my God they got Amanda!
Alright. Listen to me. Go into the next bedroom, under the bed. Tell me when you're there.
I'm here.
Now, the next part is very important.
They are going to take you.
*scream*
I don't know who you are.
I don't know what you want.
if you're looking for ransom, I can
tell you I don't have money.
...but what I do have are a very particular
set of skills.
...skills I have acquired over a very long
career.
...skills, that make me a nightmare for people like you.
Where are they?
Ooh! Argh!
If you let my daughter go now, that will be the end of it.
You have a 96 hour window.
Of what?
To never finding her.
No!!
...but if you don't. I will look for you.
WHERE IS SHE?!
I will find you
And I will kill you.
Good luck.
* "Beyond the Sea" - Bobby Darin*
Well you see my son, was taken. My son was taken away from me.